These are our polar oceans,
a part of the world that is more foreign to scientists
than the moon or Mars.
But we are getting closer to discovering
more about these crucial environments
with advanced robotic technology.
Dr. Alex Forrest is at the forefront
of that work.
His robots are built to access underneath ice shelves,
and to gather data for large-scale maps and models
that answer big-picture questions like,
"How is a shoreline changing after a storm?"
"How is toxic algae spreading?"
And, "how fast is polar ice really melting?"
The Nansen ice shelf is in Antarctica,
down in the Ross Sea,
and this ice shelf been an area of interest
because it's breaking up.
Basically, a piece of ice the size of Manhattan
broke off and drifted off, and it exposed,
in cross-sectional view,
one of these subglacial channels
that we've been trying to get access to for a while.
We're aiming to go back there again
with gliders and AUVs,
to try to understand the turbulence
and how much energy is being transported
through that system.
Energy is associated with heat,
so if we understand how much
heat is in that water,
we can understand how much
of that heat is coming from the ocean
and how much of that is coming from the ice itself.
To get a 3D picture of an ecosystem,
Alex builds tools including Autonomous Underwater Vehicles, or AUVs
with sonar, to make bathymetric maps.
He then uses gliders to sample the water column
providing him with turbulence, temperature,
salinity, chlorophyll and oxygen data.
What a glider will do, is move oil around
to displace more or less volume
to make it heavier or lighter than the water it's in.
When it reaches an inflection point, it will
pump itself light and then point upwards.
The wings create a lift and start
drawing it forward.
In here is a satellite phone connector,
a GPS receiver, and a free wave,
or radio receiver.
So we can talk to it when it's sitting
up on the surface
and tell it where to go from anywhere in the world.
All together, these chemical
and environmental fluid mechanic data
create a comprehensive model of this ecosystem.
Exploring these icy frontiers is a balancing act
of keeping people and equipment safe in
extreme weather and ocean conditions,
bringing back accurate data,
and preserving the very delicate ecosystem
we want to study.
One of the biggest challenges underwater is
that we don't have positioning.
We don't have WiFi, we can't get radio signals through, we don't have GPS...
all of these tools that we use
in regular, terrestrial mapping.
You're basically guessing where you are underwater,
so you need to develop navigation algorithms
if you're using an underwater vehicle.
Now, you put that on a ship, and then s@$%,
you all of a sudden are influenced by the waves.
So the waves, storms, et cetera will then modify
how your data looks.
What we don't want to happen is to have our
vehicle modify the fragile ecosystem that
exists at this water-ice interface.
Despite these challenges, Alex and his team
continue to gather this data
as it is one of the clearest examples
of how the planet’s climate
is changing every day.
The polar regions are changing faster than
anybody ever predicted.
It's not just a matter of large pieces of
ice shelves collapsing.
What I find more intimidating is the idea
that our sea ice volume
is at some of the lowest it's ever been before;
that the Arctic ocean temperatures are getting warmer
than ever before; that all of a sudden,
air temperatures are getting hotter.
So we need to know the baseline conditions of
today if we're to predict how they're gonna
change and evolve in the future,
and also to understand as a global community
what we're losing.